[Music]
all right
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number 178 I am Dr
Brett Weinstein this is Dr Heather Hein
and uh it's been a hell of a week but
it's always hella week now it's just the
way history has gone it is it is so
we're going to talk some about uh sport
today we're going to talk about
um the Trump arraignment some I think
and we're going to talk about
carnivorous plants obviously well I'm
glad we're going to be talking about
Sport and carnivorous plants because
there's no way those are political it
gives us a chance to get out of the
space in which things have a huge
political Dimension and uh talk about
other things that people find
interesting yeah well we are going to
finish our carnivorous plants and I
think I at least have I've not gone
looking but I have not found the
political angle on carnivorous plants so
fingers crossed I won't find it before
we get to that point in the podcast I I
have some concern that somebody will
find a political Dimension before we get
to that side yeah probably somehow word
will reach us we'll get Dragged In yep
that's that's possible people well we
are streaming on Rumble that's where the
chat is we're gonna have a q a after
this uh we encourage you to join us
there only on Rumble and tomorrow we
have our private q a that we do once
monthly where you can find that access
at our patreons we're going to talk more
about some other places you can find us
and upcoming changes to our schedule
we're actually going to come to you next
Wednesday rather than Saturday but we're
going to be talking about that again at
the end of this podcast for now I just
want to thank you for being here
encourage you to like subscribe
especially on the rumble Channel Etc and
we're gonna just jump right into our
three ads right at the top of the hour
let's do it let's do it I am first that
is shocking news but I'm ready now I was
going to say first
there it is uh our first spam sponsor no
one will be surprised to discover is
uncruise small ship Adventures on cruise
explorers by sea and by land they have
boats that hold orders of magnitude
fewer people than most cruise boats and
they take their passengers to some of
the world's most magnificent places
Panama Costa Rica Galapagos sea of
Cortez in Mexico Alaska and even in our
backyard the San Juan Islands
the small boats of uncrews allow
passengers to get real deep experience
their largest boat can accommodate a
mere 86 guests with their smallest boat
holding 22. these trips aren't about
dress codes or Glitz people crammed
cheeked by jowl unable to experience
anything about where they are
when we talked to CEO Dan Blanchard we
were thoroughly impressed by his
background his story and his ethos his
boats take small groups of people to
places that larger boats can't go and
the excursions are designed to bring
people into deep nature without
destroying it we talked about the value
of wild roadless nature about the
environmental destruction that much of
the cruise industry causes about
exploration and observation
our travel standards are high in part
because we've created and led trips to
many of the places on cruise goes and
we've seen firsthand that most tours do
not match the hype our hopes were
extremely high for uncruise though and
uncruise did not disappoint they took us
along on a recent week-long trip through
the Inland Waters of Southeast Alaska
from Glacier Bay through the tongas
national forest and down into Tracy arm
we were blown away by what we saw and
what we were able to do and I will say
this is one of those trips that I have
thought about many times since we got
back and it's not always the case with
trips but in this case it gave us a lot
to think about your experience as well
absolutely uh you know it's a contiguous
the ecosystem is contiguous with where
we live and so in some ways it is less
different than it was for a number of
the other people who were on board you
know people who don't live anywhere near
the Pacific Northwest rarely if ever
have seen a bald eagle that sort of
thing but it was no less extraordinary
um for you know in part for being able
to compare how different it is even
though many of the actual organisms that
we were looking for and finding are the
same as what we have here in the San
Juans how different it is and I was
completely struck by how impossible it
would be to see those things without the
help of uncruise you could go on a big
ship and see maybe some of them at a
very great distance but to get involved
this is really the only way to do it we
saw sea otters with their pups mountain
goats eagles and their nests brown and
black bears puffins orcas humpbacks
Arctic turns too many species to list
and mile after mile of the most
breathtaking scenery it was definitely
not a trip for people who want to just
look at the view from the deck of a boat
though each day we got out into the
environment hiking kayaking skiff
touring and yes even a cold Plunge at
the foot of a glacier Burr for those who
were so inclined and we were so inclined
we were also stunned by how well we were
taken care of the crew and naturalist
guides were to a person-kind
knowledgeable and enthusiastic the food
was surprisingly good and food
preferences and sensitivities were
handled perfectly and I mean perfectly
uncruz understands that the boat is just
a tool their small ship cruises take
guests through the communities and
locales on the ground so they can have
actual experiences with every sailing
with uncrews all inclusive
Transportation drinks Farm to Table
Cuisine daily excursions everything is
included
on cruise is giving Dark Horse listeners
a fantastic deal 500 bucks off their
current cruises an offer that you can
combine with other savings including
their last minute spring to Alaska trips
which are already discounted so start
planning your next trip with uncrews
today and take advantage of our great
offer go to uncrews.com Pages slash
Darkhorse remember to save 500 bucks on
your trip go to uncrews.com Pages slash
Darkhorse again that's uncrews.com Pages
slash Darkhorse
all right our second sponsor this week
is Seoul s-o-l-e sole footbeds are the
original custom moldable insoles
providing affordable pain relief since
2001.
sole footbeds include signature
supportive Arch which is clinically
proven to reduce Arch strain in your
feet and these foot beds are great for
any Arch height if you have low arches
or flat feet you simply heat mold them
in your oven at home to ensure a
comfortable level of support
anecdotally I'm going to tell you that
sole footbeds have been a game changer
for me I was born with weird feet weird
enough that I had a reconstructive
surgery on both of them when I was 13
which put me in a wheelchair for months
and very extremely ugly orthopedic shoes
for a year after that that surgery was
wildly successful though and I was
playing Varsity Sports within a couple
years of having it but it's been a while
since I was 13 and my arches are
beginning to flatten my feet hurt a lot
more than they used to wearing shoes
with sole footbeds in them is helping
tremendously I have sole footbeds in my
extra tough Boots the very ones that I
was wearing in Alaska and in my hiking
boots and even in a pair of shoes that
you might go to a nice restaurant in not
that I haven't gone to nice restaurants
and hiking boots I have
they have multiple styles for different
kinds of activity if you have any foot
issues at all you should seriously try
these footbeds
sole footbeds are easily customizable
using your oven at home or you can skip
that step and they'll mold to your feet
over a few days you get the benefits of
personalized support at a small fraction
of the price of Dr prescribed Orthotics
and they're made from recycled quark
sole foot beds also reduce pain from
plantar fasciitis and shin splints they
promote neutral alignment and good
posture and are particularly effective
at preventing fatigue when standing or
walking for long hours on hard surfaces
two-thirds of people who try sole
footbeds come back for a second pair and
many have trusted soul to keep their
feet energized and pain-free for more
than 20 years if you've ever wondered
whether Orthotics could add to your
comfort or athletic performance this is
your chance to find out what 16 million
satisfied Souls already know
as a dark horse listener you can now try
swell footbeds for free simply go to
yoursoul.com Darkhorse or enter the code
Darkhorse at checkout to try Soul
footbeds free today that's your soul
y-r-u-r-s-o-l-e.com slash Darkhorse or
enter the code Darkhorse at checkout for
any pair of footbeds on yoursoul.com try
Soul free today and say goodbye to sore
feet terms and conditions apply I will
just add to that when we first were
signed up with Seoul they sent us some
flip-flops and I'm not a flip-flop guy
but because we don't wear shoes in the
house I have been using the flip-flops
just throw them on to go do something
outside and they're actually great I I'm
re-evaluating the wisdom of flip-flops
in some circumstances they're so good
indeed they are
and our final sponsor this week is seed
a probiotic that really works your gut
and your immune system work together
coordinating your body's response to the
world both around and within you seed
helps improve the health of your gut
microbiome which means that it supports
you becoming healthier overall
our resident gut microbes directly
impact the development and function of
the immune system even before we're born
microbes microbes it's not a thing it's
not is it a yeah I don't think I can
even make it into a thing before we're
born microbes inform our immune system
teaching our body how to distinguish
between benign substances and pathogenic
antigens that is the substances that our
body doesn't recognize as its own
you can support your gut immune access
in a variety of ways of course including
by prioritizing sleep your body operates
on a 24-hour cycle your circadian rhythm
new research suggests that the gut
microbiome has its own circadian clock
and that changes to your normal rhythms
can disrupt your microbes not your
microbes but your microbes and the
important functions that they perform
prioritizing regular insufficient sleep
can thus help get your immune axis your
gut immune access healthy you can also
support your gut immune access by taking
seeds dso1 daily symbiotic that's syn
biotic seed is a plant-based Prebiotic
and probiotic with 24 strains that have
been clinically or scientifically
studied for their benefits
16 of those 24 strains were specifically
geared towards Digestive Health as you
would expect from a probiotic and four
of the 24 probiotic strains are known to
promote healthy skin your skin like your
gut has its own microbiome seed supports
both gut and skin health
seed is free from 14 major classes of
allergens including but not limited to
sugar animal products soy gluten peanut
glyphosate Dairy shellfish and corn and
seed is basically double hauled with its
capsule in capsule design it is
engineered to maintain viability through
your through your digestive tract until
it reaches your colon where you want it
and the same design makes it resistant
to oxygen moisture and heat meaning that
no Refrigeration is necessary this is
not a fussy probiotic like so many are
seeds daily symbiotic supports gut skin
and heart health and micronutrient
synthesis we have heard from several
people who have used seed and Report
improvements to their digestive function
in 24 to 48 hours so start a new healthy
habit today visit seed.com Darkhorse and
use code Darkhorse to redeem 25 off your
first month of seeds DSO one daily
symbiotic that's seed.com Darkhorse and
use code Darkhorse
foreign
let's
start
talking about sport all right sport yeah
um so this week in Natural Selections I
wrote my in on in my uh
the place where I write weekly and
um many people read what I write weekly
I wrote about yet another
somewhat talented but basically mediocre
male athlete who's being allowed to
compete as a woman and uh he's beating
the woman
because
um
because we are a species with
with sexual dimorphism and we are
sexually reproducing and have been
uninterruptedly for at least 500 million
years and those two things in
combination mean that there are two
Sexes only two Sexes you can't change
between them and uh the male of the
species in in us and in mammals
generally is a bit larger a bit stronger
and you can't undo those things by uh by
taking cross-x hormones later in life or
indeed by taking puberty blockers you
can't you can't undo uh the differences
between the sexes
um you can suppress some of them but you
cannot undo them so
um
the title of my piece that I wrote about
this was in um a bike race 134 mile I
think bike race yeah over 40 of which is
off off-road there's a lot of single
track there's rocks there's sand there's
Cactus apparently
um there's water features water feature
sounds weird like there's there's that
sounds like a golf course
like an arboretum yeah yeah but I
imagine you know we we have done our
Fair never this like never that right
but we've done a fair share of single
track
um mountain biking and you know these
sort of like downhill single track where
it's getting a little slippery because
it's Sandy and then suddenly you're in
the water and it's Rocky now you've got
to climb and it's loose and uh you know
that that's sort of what I have in my
head although 134 miles of it with four
almost 14 000 feet of vertical gain like
this is this this is serious and the
water features are more like water bugs
yeah I don't know if they're being like
chased by biting flies too but uh
and the people who are most directly
chased tend to win no no uh the people
who um tend to win are the the women's
race now are the men who are
masquerading as women
because they would yeah you have to have
some skill like you you know you gotta
you gotta have skill to get through 134
mile race 131 I can't remember which it
is over 130 mile race uh over 40 of
which is in the dirt uh 14 000 vertical
feet again like you know just it's a
hard race regardless but
um you know over and over we're seeing
men who were doing okay in the men's
division they say oh I know
I know what I'm allowed to do now
I get to claim I'm a woman okay and they
start competing
as women
uh and in the case of the this this
particular character that seems to
mostly mean that he wears dangly
earrings
um that's apparently the source of
Womanhood and and he wins and the woman
who came in second was
gracious
maybe even a little bit too gracious uh
but said and actually here let me find
her exact line and I quote her in my
piece uh she says
it's Paige on Weller who came in second
says I couldn't match Austin in some of
the single track the power is not just
it's just not comparable
and you know this is this is one-off you
know it's it's possible that uh you know
we've we've got it wrong and
um you know one one sporting event Was
Won by someone who claims to be trans
and
um maybe it would be fair otherwise but
this is just example after example after
example and uh women's bicycling is
falling just as many women's sports are
so there are a number of directions that
I think are are worth exploring here
um one is there's a question really
about what the motivator is for some of
these folks in other words if you were a
middling male athlete in a sport in
which there was no hope of you getting
to the elite level because you have to
be you know this is the tale of a
distribution there aren't very many
people who can can reach it it's not
just a matter of stick-to-itiveness so
if you find yourself unable to reach the
elite level and you crave you know the
trappings of victory
then you discover that actually oh the
world has become uh blind to absurdity
and you can simply opt into a protected
categories uh separate Sports Division
and suddenly you are an elite athlete
not by virtue of you having done what
the elite athletes do or being
extraordinary in the way that they are
but simply by changing your category
then
um you can win now when I think about
these stories the same thing trips me up
every time
I can't imagine doing that and not being
embarrassed by the win just mortified
mortified by having obviously treated so
that's and let me just say I've I've
said I was going to say but the piece
that I wrote I called celebrating the
cheater how to beat women in the 21st
century
so
when I see these people interviewed and
they express Pride like oh this was so
hard yeah it was you know it's a hundred
and what do you say 34 mile largely
off-road 131 mile bike race 14 000 feet
of vertical climb 14.
the particle climb which is more than 40
off-road 14 000 feet that's like
climbing uh Mount Whitney from sea level
yeah right in the middle of the third
Century one in the third century is
largely Opera this is a brutal brutal
race yeah so you know everybody who did
it is you know they have accomplished
something but oh absolutely as for
whether or not you were a winner in that
field if you had uh changed your sex in
some by some measure to join a category
in which the you are farther down the
tail of the distribution and then you
win pride is not what you should be
feeling and when and because not only
did you cheat but you took a bunch of
people who are at the tail of the
distribution who rode the Same Damn Race
as you did and kicked ass and the point
is you're excluding them from Glory that
they earn you're not only getting glory
for yourself that you're not entitled to
but you're you're excluding people who
did it the honorable way from Glory that
they're entitled to and
I can't imagine having a camera pointed
at you in that moment but and having the
emotion and then saying the emotion
Pride right right so anyway I guess I
guess my point would be
foreign
maybe it's not surprising that the same
person who would go through a so-called
gender transition in order to become an
elite athlete right become an elite
athlete by you know a redefinitional
uh feat yeah mostly it's it's I I don't
know all of the rules across all of all
of these things but very often it's just
self ID right I'm a woman now
no you're not you're never going to be
you're never going to be but
let's put it this way we do know people
we don't know why this has happened to
them but we do know people who have been
tormented by the sex that they were born
to and have faced the frightening and
unpleasant Prospect of some sort of a
transition in order to feel better okay
but that's one of two paths here right
it could be that you something about the
condition that you're born into whether
it's a hormonal disruption or an ancient
phenomenon that emerges at some rate or
whatever it is right that's one way is
that you could be motivated by whatever
it is that drives people to do this or
you could be motivated by the
opportunities it avails you of and this
and this person Austin Phillips is his
name
um was like so many I'm not going to say
all because I don't know for sure but
like so many of these male athletes who
are now beating women
uh be by claiming to be women and
getting to compete against them which
why are we allowing this to happen but
they weren't like they were competing as
men until just a couple years ago right
right like they it's it's not that they
transitioned you know way earlier than
we ever should have had children
transition and they're coming up and
that's that still would not be fair
right but these are these are these are
people who were trying to make it as
athletes and we're not winning at it and
saw a way in and we shouldn't be
surprised that people will take that
opportunity but we should be surprised
at is that we are offering the
opportunity right the opportunity is
absurd but it is not surprising it's
surprising to me because I think I'm
normal in this regard but it should not
be surprising to us that somebody who's
willing to use that Gateway is also
surprisingly death to the fact that
they've just uh hurt people who
ostensibly they share a sport with right
right if you're passionate about
mountain biking and you just drove some
you know Elite female mountain biker
from the podium by pretending you're
that you were a woman right you
shouldn't be feeling Pride but maybe the
same kind of person who would cheat in
the way would also be the kind of person
who wouldn't recognize that their pride
is completely out of place in the
circumstance exactly the same this the
same dude who just beat
um several women in this 131 mile race
uh said in a piece published in May of
this year in cycling news he said it's
incredibly painful to be othered
and
um cyclist Hannah erinsman who is no
longer competing professionally uh
having finished fourth behind kellips in
the U.S cyclocross championship event in
December 2022
presumably feels rather differently
about what kellips is going through said
Aaronson Aaron Smith as she was or
having just retired from biking
professional biking at a young age she
says I feel for young girls learning to
compete and who are growing up in a day
when they no longer have a fair chance
at being the new record holders and
champions in cycling
so do I right now this the idea you know
it's almost like it's a game right that
okay you're gonna cheat to get into this
thing you're gonna get on the podium
then you're gonna say a bunch of stuff
and you're going to like you know pull a
bunch of tricks to make sure nobody
notices what you're up to which is well
if you notice what I'm up to then you're
othering me and you have no idea how
painful that is and you wouldn't want to
cause somebody pain would you and you
know two things actually work in the
same direction here not only obviously
is it going to be natal males who are
competing against women who are winning
right like middle women Committee
Against males are not going to win but
also the women they're competing against
being women are more likely to be
agreeable and more likely to go like Ah
that's like I know that's not fair but
I'm just I don't like the confrontation
I'm just gonna let it go and you know I
think increasingly female athletes are
not of course it's not letting it go but
they but it is you know it it this is
one of the differences between the sex
is that women are more likely to be
agreeable that's a you know a term of
Art in Psychology here where you know
not being as interested in conversation
wanting to go along to get along and
well when a Dude shows up in your midst
and you know wearing earrings and says
I'm a woman now uh some number of women
even knowing for sure that they are
absolutely being lied to are going to
you know are gonna are gonna fail the
test are gonna say yeah you know that
Ash the ash Conformity experiment right
um you know women are more likely to
fail this ash Conformity than men are
this is It's been redone many many times
the original just ash Conformity was in
like the late 50s I think 60s I believe
late 50s or early 60s I I thought it was
late 50s but somewhere in there
mid-century
and uh you know it was it was done at
that point with all male undergraduates
and that's that's going to be the test
where you know I gotta remember exactly
but you know you've shown three lines or
something right three lines are put on
the board of obviously different lengths
of obviously different lengths uh and uh
and you go into the room and you don't
know if you're the subject of the
experiment that everyone else in the
room is actually part of the part of
um that they they have been told what to
do they are Confederates hired by the
experiment to pretend to be subjects
right and so if you know you as the
person being experimented on are last in
a line of three or four and are asked
okay just you know which line is shorter
or you know is this line shorter or
longer than the other and it's patently
obvious it's a simple question of fact
if everyone before you gives the wrong
answer a surprising number of people are
much more likely to look around go like
am I missing where am I here and give
the wrong answer as well
and uh very few people give the wrong
answer all of the time but a
surprisingly large majority give the
wrong answer some of the time when the
people around them have already publicly
declared a patently wrong answer so
that's the the original version and I
you know I don't remember all of the
exact numbers here but it's been redone
a lot a lot of times it's one of these
things that does replicate it's it's one
of these experiments on a psychology
that does replicate and it's been done
with women and
um it there's even a stronger pattern of
conformity in women than in men and this
is going to be directly related to the
agreeableness that women have which in
some circumstances
um is is likely to be a good thing right
it's not that agreeableness is
inherently a bad thing but it is
something to be aware of if there is you
know a wolf in sheep's clothing in your
midst it's not actually a good thing to
pretend that's a sheep there's a there's
actually a deep irony here right which
is
um
the reason that males and females are
dimorphic by size is about
disagreeableness in a sense right it is
the fact of male conflict having
distorted evolutionarily distorted male
form from the optimal ecological form
the form that you would have if
exploiting the resources of the world
was uh was what you were built for males
have been distorted by conflict with
other males and so the idea that females
are
less athletically
powerful because of the Distortion of
males and now these distorted males
who've had their power increased to
fight with other males are now going to
be in competition with females is pretty
absurd right it's you know it's uh it's
turning the whole thing on its head
but I wanted to come back to this
question of of the otherness right who
claim that oh it's so painful to be
othered right yes incredibly painful
this is in a you know you have to be you
have to squint at it just right to see
it but this person is participating in
the other ring of half the population oh
yes women who are simply born female and
mature into women right
that's not something it's not supposed
to be subject to somebody's definitional
games or sophistry or anything else it's
a simple fact you are entitled to be in
this category and there are some burdens
that come with that category and there's
some privileges that come with that
category and you you get the package but
now suddenly we've got men pretending to
be women and women being demoted from
their own category right we have all of
these absurdities like well we wouldn't
want to you know other the trans women
so that means we have to not refer to
the normal characteristics of women as
if they're normal because some of the
people who are now women don't have them
right so we're going to go through the
absurdity of saying chest feeding rather
than breastfeeding and birthing people
rather than women or whatever the
absurdity is
how could that possibly be a greater
feat of othering right it's like the
ultimate othering half the population is
now second-class citizens by virtue of
the fact that a tiny number of people
wish to join their category and
therefore you know upset the entire
apple cart right and
you know was it Johns Hopkins this week
that they've since taken down
um their definition of gay and lesbian I
don't know about the the definition of
lesbian that was published was a non-man
attracted to a non-man
wait a second that would seem to include
cows cows pretty much I mean even plants
if you look at it right yeah even this
pen except probably doesn't have
attractive wait a second no it looked
watch oh yeah let's see an interaction
it's a lesbian interaction the pen
attracted to the earth I mean that's
beastiality actually if you look at it
right
um I feel like there were no animals
involved there it's just like a cross
type everything that any of those
objects were attracted to was not a
person
I don't know I'm not good at this office
Street thing I could probably practice
but
um anyway yeah no but I the the
campaign to make
this into a civil rights fight right and
and where someone can say apparently
apparently with no self-awareness or
embarrassment
how incredibly painful it is to be
othered at the point that you are
kicking ass over actual women in the
sport that they have trained very very
hard to to be superior at
is
extraordinary like this is this is a
loss of civil rights not a gain of civil
rights this is this is a this is a loss
for as you say half the population and
you know and it's and it's more than
that because you know if we're talking
about sport it's half the population but
if we're talking about the other ways
that the ideology is marching forward
it's of course
um celebrating transness over being
homosexual it's you know it's it's
increasing the ability for people to be
actually homophobic right like actually
be scared of their own sexual attraction
um and by claiming something that's not
possible which is that they're the other
sex that they're not and of course it's
putting Children at Risk because we've
talked about extensively and as I've
written about extensively
um so I wanted to throw an
interpretation at you
um
sport
is obviously a big category there's a
fair amount of work on the evolution of
sport yeah and one of the things that is
certainly true within the realm of sport
is that it functions as a kind of
training practice for other things
um you know team sports Warfare most
most obviously
but let's just take the idea
that sport is a training ground for
skills that are valuable in other parts
of adult life yes and I don't know quite
what to I don't know if this is an
accidental fact or if there is something
driving here but it strikes me that
the rearrangement of the rules
surrounding what you have to be to
participate in women's sports in order
to accommodate trans or nominally trans
folks many of whom appear to be eager to
cheat and not just to play sport with
women but to beat them because they're
not women right that what this is
actually doing is training people for
skills that are highly relevant in
modern times right this has nothing to
do with what we think of you know uh the
thrill of victory and the agony of
defeat the things that we traditionally
think of in conjunction with
sportsmanship and the other things that
go along with you know Elite play
um
but what this is training people for is
capture right this is this is men
capturing women's sport it's training
them for
sophistry right another skill of the
moment if you're good at sophistry this
is your era and it's trading them for
cheating as you point out that and
basically here here's here's the the
punchline of this so capture sophistry
and cheating yep capture sophistry and
cheating which are three skills that
really should not be elevated but at the
moment they might be three of the most
important skills for functioning in the
modern era these are the things that put
you ahead and anybody who decides to
play by the rules anybody who's
interested in sportsmanship anybody who
is interested in independent Regulators
or independent thought or analysis that
is designed to find out what's true
rather than Advance a particular
perspective as if it were true
right all of those things you know these
are skills we shouldn't be training
anybody in but apparently we are
training them and here's the training
ground can you talk your way onto the
podium rather than ride your way onto
the podium yeah right yeah that's that's
that's right
I feel that's I think that's highly apt
and I'm wondering
about you know so both of us played a
fair bit of Ultimate Frisbee when we
were younger
um both highly competitively and then
just a lot of a lot of pickup you know
some you know for a couple Summers four
or five games a week I never played
competitively you did I played pickup
exclusively
okay
um I thought you a couple a couple I
mean lots of leagues but yeah nothing
yeah
um
but uh but we both we both
played a lot saw a lot
um and yeah I I traveled and um and and
played competitively as well and one of
the things even
um certainly in like summer leagues
where it was competitive but you know
Stakes are low uh but also like on the
on the Michigan Women's team which is
the team that I I played with
competitively
um there was an emphasis always in the
game at the Casual level but also with
the formal level on
um self-refereeing
on
um calling your own fouls on recognizing
When Something's Happened on you know
when you're playing pickup or written
with newbies
um you know halting play in order to
explain something if they don't know why
something has happened the way it's
happened right it's actually in the
official rules yeah and
um it's wonderful and it you know it
sounds like it could be you know kind of
woo and like you know you know what the
hell don't we do don't we just want to
play guys like but no it actually it
actually really really works and you
know people who just you can't yet throw
Frisbee and won't figure it out are not
going to be welcome very long because
it's just a pain to have such people
um you know on the field with you
um but especially for you know low
stakes pickup games or even leagues
summer leagues uh it's really it's
really remarkable how many different
ages and uh it can play together how
many different skill levels can play
together the different ages you've got
different strategies right like you know
the older older players are not going to
be running long to receive the hawk in
the end zone mostly right they're going
to be strategizing and figuring out
exactly where to place the disc and hope
you know and maybe
um you know some other slightly older
um player who doesn't have the you know
stamina to beat everyone else down the
field is going to figure out where to
cut and and receive the perfectly desk
but similarly men and women play
together really effectively it's one of
the few team sports where co-ed is and
it was my favorite like I preferred
playing co-ed
um to playing all women's games or to
watching all men's games all win the all
women's games tended to be a little
ponderous a little bit slow you know
there's a little bit more focus on like
everyone's got to handle the discs like
oh come on can we just like can we try
to win a point here and you know of
course that that's an exaggeration
um but they there was you know you
rarely got the long hooks down the field
in a women's game whereas in the men's
game the points stand to be very fast
and you know usually it was the same two
guys like you know as soon as one guy
has the disc he knows that his the other
guy's gonna run and that's it right
short points uh and not as interesting
to watch and also presumably not as
interesting to play unless you're one of
those guys right
so the coed games though they had both
of those energies and uh and it was
great and it worked if you're doing man
on defense or zone or like it just it
just worked across the board
well it wouldn't have worked though hold
on if if
um
if you had someone who was who was
claiming things that weren't true and
that doesn't make sense in a co-ed
situation because actually no it does
well it wouldn't work for if you're
claiming to be a man or a woman
um but well it would because
um the way this works and forgive us is
this is worthwhile to understand why it
is that this game unlike others does
work co-ed yeah um
It's a Wonderful game but the
sportsmanship is built in it's literally
unrefereed in most circumstances and
it's self-referied and that means you
really do say yeah I did not you know I
did touch that disc before it hit the
ground therefore there's a turnover
right right so that kind of thing you
you nobody lies in this game if they're
playing it correctly I guess it hits the
ground that's a turnover regardless I
guess so but um I have known it's been a
while long enough but anyway the point
is as a point as a point is about to
begin in a man on defense man on man
defense
um which is most points in most pickup
games you line up across from the person
that you are going to cover right and
the point is the teams would be chosen
so they would end up relatively even
even number of strong players on both
teams otherwise it's no fun and then the
strongest players line up against each
other and typically the way that would
work is if there are women evenly
divided behind between the teams which
there typically would be the women would
line up on each other and so the point
is it balances at the level of the
individual across the whole team now if
you had a woman who was
excellent and you had a man who was not
quite as elevated in play there's
nothing wrong with the two of them
lining up against
no doubt no doubt so anyway but my point
is within the team the expectation is
that you as a man are not going to line
up against a woman because you can shut
her down you're going to line up against
a woman because you're evenly matched
and it is that self-assessment of evenly
matched and therefore this makes sense
right and if you violated it right if
you did decide hey let's make some
points by uh you know shutting down
certain players and blah blah blah blah
blah if you did that right it would be
frowned on right nobody would view that
as a success they would view it as a
failure right and you know it this this
presumes the teams are relatively evenly
matched so you know one of the ways this
self-correct is that the teams are
relatively evenly matched if you uh say
oh I'm gonna line up against someone
who's clearly uh my inferior as a player
that presumably leaves someone else uh
undefended who's clearly Superior with a
uh an inferior defense and at least in
in pickup games you know you don't do
this when you're playing competitively
obviously but in pickup or even in
leagues
um if if you start playing and you know
again we were playing pickup a lot and
so we tended to know that you know all
of us tend to know who who was showing
up and what our various skills were but
you know people have off days people
have extraordinary days and so you kind
of pick teams and you start playing and
if after a couple points it's really
clear yeah like these this this is not
going to be fun for anyone like one team
is going to feel like amazing except
it's just not fun like you came to play
sport you claim you came to be involved
in athletic ability athletic activity
with group of people who are like-minded
and also interested in being outside
throwing a disc around in a nice day and
also matching your skills and your wits
against them and so if it's not an even
match you come together after a few
points be like okay let's swap a couple
people yeah and you don't
you know if you're one of the people who
swapped onto the team um that was doing
better you don't feel bad about it
you're just like you know what that's
how it is I you know I like and and if
you're one of the ones who swapped on
the team that was doing worse you do
feel a little good about that but it's
that's not what it's about it's about
the team sportness of it and you know
biking is not a team well biking can be
but in this case this
um this 131 mile
um largely off-road event is not a team
sport
but I guess I don't understand how some
part of that like we're doing this
because we're matching our skills and
our wits against one another ethos isn't
in part of everyone who thinks of
themselves as an athlete I don't I don't
understand it and I do get the people
will cheat if you give them the
opportunity but I also I guess I guess
I'm coming sort of Full Circle to where
you started it's like I can't imagine
wanting to do that right can't imagine
wanting to do it but I also think that
this is
um
what was your developmental environment
yeah and the problem is as we've come to
in many of the issues that we've covered
here
the younger Generations are faced with
the world in which a larger fraction of
the things that trigger a dopamine
release
are mediated through the online
environment right yeah and so
there effectively is no or was no online
environment aspect to Ultimate it was
something you went and you did and you
didn't you know frankly most of the
pickup games that we played half of them
at least I would say the only point that
anybody remembered was the last one
right we may have a sense that we got
more points than they did during a game
but people weren't keeping track because
the whole point was it was never the it
was never the point right it was never
the point right even though like you you
oh absolutely like I I we want to win
this point and we are an entity that
came together 30 seconds ago and will
last for 20 minutes or an hour or maybe
two hours and then we will disband and
we'll come back together tomorrow or
three days from now and it'll be a
different we and we want to win like
that's awesome yeah but it also has no
meaning outside of exactly that it has
no meaning and therefore there didn't
need to be a scoreboard and nobody
needed to keep track and the fact is it
was just as fun or more fun yeah because
the point was you know what you
remembered was you know you did
something extraordinary you know you
laid out in the end zone and you got the
point even though nobody thought you
were going to do it so anyway all of
that stuff is there but the scoreboard
at the end and the accolades weren't
right didn't pick up games yeah I
usually pick up would be like okay you
know we've been playing for a while it's
getting like okay game to three game to
seven like should we should we cap this
because otherwise a bunch of us are just
never going to want to leave because
we're kind of addicted to it right yeah
um so I guess the the for me there's a
contrast between what's motivating you
to participate and you know look
I know how hard it must be to ride what
was it 134 miles 31 131 miles largely
off-road 14
000. I mean let's let's put it this way
there's never been a day in my life when
I could have accomplished that right
that is that is beyond any any of my
highest level of capacity never reached
that
um you could have I couldn't I think I
think both of us could have trained for
it I could have trained to accomplish it
I couldn't have competed at that
distance but like could could I have
could you have trained yeah yeah
probably I could
131 miles with yeah 40 of it off-road is
hard and especially 14 000 feet of climb
that's all yeah that's a little yeah so
I'm not even convinced I could have
completed it but
um
but anyway the point is okay
hard for me to imagine that you would do
that
because what you really wanted to do was
brag enough that you were willing to you
know cheat right like I don't I cannot
get into the mindset we're cheating
that's too big an investment Go cheat on
something easier right right that's a
huge expenditure of effort and you know
and equally of equal magnitude to the
amazing effort there is the fact that
other people who put in that same effort
are excluded from credit you should feel
terrible that you would do that but
anyway contrast that's like the inverse
of a sport in which who won actually
nobody may even know at the end of the
game and nobody cares right the idea
that the sport itself the camaraderie of
being on the team even if it's momentary
so
you know what are we training people for
that's really the question
are we training people to you know to
become really dedicated cheaters Yes
because that's what this is yes we are
yes we are and so you're
you're the the three Salient skills that
we are training people for that you
named just to wrap this up or capture
sophistry and cheating
yeah yeah and uh in fact when you and I
were talking a little bit about this
before uh and I was describing this
situation to you what you said was he's
cheating with pride
yeah cheating with pride which is a
stunning yeah a stunning thing it really
speaks to a kind of uh defect that's
hard to hard to relate to and I don't
mean to be a hard on this particular
individual but it does seem to me
probably this individual is not going to
care because they're obviously quite
comfortable with uh you know
driving women out of their own sport
that's right
all right well I like um that as part of
that we discovered that uh gravity uh
creates lesbians I think that is what we
discovered right so if you were missing
that part of the conversation I
encourage you to go back and figure out
what I'm talking about I think people
who were just listening are not going to
have any idea why my pen is having
lesbian interactions and with whom but
uh with what I mean I don't you don't
want to um other the table
I'm going out to the table because
here's the thing
if
oh I guess they're both right no no
here's the point right
uh but we're gonna need a term but
here's the thing
the definition of a lesbian interaction
was a non-man non-man attracted to a
non-man and in this case my pen had
decidedly non-man is attracted not to
the table
but to the earth the earth so what's the
table doing
it's uh
[Laughter]
you see my point yeah yeah yeah yeah
um I it's not [__] blocking no it's not
we need a synonym for pen that
so it's almost a whole big table oh it's
a pyramid table that's it okay yeah no
it's not down with lesbianism
all right who knew you learned something
new about your table every day that's
not true
there are days when you learn new things
about your table yes
um all right then you wanted to follow
up
um on some of the stuff you were talking
about last week with regard to the
indictment and uh and and now and now I
did former president and I would ask
people to uh to bear with us right the
reason to revisit this is that actually
we've learned something new in the
intervening time since uh last week
um where uh we talked specifically about
the question of Donald Trump the
classified documents that were found at
Mar-A-Lago and that he makes no bones
about the fact that he brought there
from when he was president
and the indictment of him for uh
stealing classified documents
and I laid out what I thought was the
best defense which I think is actually
you know I'm not a legal expert but I
did consult legal experts and I think
completely compelling which is he's the
president he has the right to declassify
documents at any time for any reason any
document he wants there is apparently no
procedure for doing so so it's not even
that he forgot to file the papers and
that basically by walking out of the
Oval Office with those documents he
Declassified them and doesn't look like
a crime certainly not a crime worth
putting somebody in jail over right
Federal indictment on criminal charges
um certainly not a crime that we would
risk becoming a Banana Republic over
where not only is a former president
being put on trial for a crime that
almost certainly isn't a crime and if it
is a crime is almost certainly a trivial
crime because he had the right to
declassify those documents with some
sort of a magic spell or whatever it is
that the Democrats imagine he should
have done
um but the point is this is also you
know the Biden Administration
putting on trial it's leading uh
opponent in the Republican party this is
this is
uh
Banana Republic [__]
but anyway is he is he leading yeah I
believe he is leading
um I believe he is leading and you know
I also think
um in addition to being diabolical the
DNC in
urging the bite Administration to do
this which is no doubt what happened is
also mind-bogglingly stupid because it
is creating the very powerful argument
that the force that controls our
politics and does diabolical things is
its leading opponent is Trump right
they're creating another argument for
electing Trump which I think is a
mistake I don't think he's the right guy
for the job I've never thought he was
but they are making an argument that's
pretty hard to ignore right which is
that the the power structure the Deep
state or whatever it is seems to really
dislike this guy and have to threaten
him with prison maybe he really is you
know the thing that they fear most in
which case you've just made an argument
for him but anyway I wanted to cover
um the somewhat more subtle developments
uh of of this last week
so Trump was uh arraigned in Miami and
he
um gave a speech in New Jersey after
that arraignment
and the
speech I watched the speech
absolutely fascinating but I wanna
highlight what MSNBC did in response to
an obviously historical event
right a former president being uh
charged with a felony that I think could
put him in jail for 400 years or
something absurd like this seems like a
long time it's a long time but you know
the idea that he's on trial for
something that could put him in prison
is
a very profound turn of events it is it
is decidedly important whether you think
he's absolutely guilty and this is a
major compromise of national security or
you think as we said last week it's a
nothing burger with no Patty right
either way this is
big news right I you said that I did we
did not you're not signing on to that
formulation but uh
um but anyway can we can we play the uh
I need to say that former president
Trump has just started uh making public
remarks just as he did on the evening of
his first arraignment on criminal
charges that was April when he was
booked on 34 felony accounts brought by
the state of New York now tonight after
his arraignment on federal felony
charges he's speaking again this time to
an audience of his supporters that's
gathered for a campaign fundraiser
tonight at his his golf club and summer
home in New Jersey
um we knew heading into this that he was
planning to make these remarks we are
prepared for his pre-fundraiser remarks
tonight to again be essentially a trump
campaign speech because of that we do
not intend to carry these remarks live
um as we have said before in these
circumstances
there is a cost to us as a news
organization to knowingly broadcast
untrue things we are here to bring you
the news it hurts our ability to do that
if we live broadcast what we fully
expect in advance to be a Litany of lies
and false accusations no matter who says
them
and I do not say this with any Glee I
hope it is clear that this is not a glib
decision we take our responsibilities
seriously we revisit decisions like this
all the time we make the best call that
we can in real time every time
but tonight our call is this we will
monitor that speech by the newly
indicted former president we will not
carry his remarks live if he says
anything newsworthy we promise we will
turn that right around and bring it back
to you
all right now
what MSNBC says and what Rachel Maddow
elucidates here
is that they are not going to cover
president Trump's
response to his arraignment because
they've already decided that is going to
be full of lies and as a news
organization
broadcasting lies compromises their
credibility
because they're not going to broadcast
it live she doesn't say they're not
going to cover
the speech well I don't know what they
did but what she says is they're not
going to broadcast it a lot fair enough
but a I do not believe they broadcast
the speech they may have I don't know
taken a clip or two but here here I
don't think we need to split hairs here
she says we are not going to cover it
live because we already expect it to be
full of lies we are a news organization
and lies are bad for us to broadcast
okay she does this is a nonsense on
several different fronts
one this is a former president of the
United States as far as I know the first
president of the United States indicted
on criminal charges
his response if he cries if he breaks
out in a beautiful Aria whatever his
response to that is is news
it turns out that the speech in question
contains
a
detailed analysis of his defense
it is absolutely cogently argued by
Trump
he does present exactly the defense I
talked about last week
okay he says I am not guilty of a crime
and what's more Joe Biden is guilty of a
crime because Joe Biden did the same
thing took documents home and he was
vice president had no right to take them
home he was not allowed to declassify
them so the point is first of all
you can discover something about MSNBC
in the fact that they have decided that
this is going to be a speech of lies and
they are not going to cover its campaign
speech right again they're not going to
broadcast it live right but nonetheless
different from not covering it
and again like I don't I have no idea if
they did or did not cover it but what
the statement that you just showed us is
Rachel Maddow saying we're not going to
broadcast this live that that is the
thing that she is fair enough however
this is a news organization what they
have done is prejudge the speech
Prejudice prejudged they have decided
what the content of the speech is going
to be and the best thing you could say
is that they weren't going to broadcast
it live because they expected it to be
lives that's already a violation of
their obligation as a news organization
to broadcast this newsworthy speech lies
yeah I don't know uh whatever it would
be we have a right to know what it is
and what they are doing is they are
behaving in at what is a
non-journalistic paternalistic fashion
at best and really what they're doing is
they're using the excuse of paternalism
we're not going to let you hear what he
said we're going to judge it for you in
advance and prevent you from being able
to hear it
they are doing that because frankly what
Trump said
is
highly compelling and raises but the
point of the decision was made they
didn't know that because it was a
question of whether or not they're going
to broadcast it okay but so they were
predicting they were they were making a
prediction
um they may or may not have that
prediction sounds like I don't know uh
was falsified but
yeah but here's the test they're
I guess if I'm if I'm going to Steel Man
the MSNBC decision here
there is a lot of stuff that is
newsworthy and they are making editorial
decisions all the time about what to and
to not show
in addition again trying to steal many
MSNBC position here uh if you have a
policy that
um under X you know this is the list of
things which will always inherently be
newsworthy and therefore if this has
happened to you we will broadcast live
something something something
um then that will be gamed and there
will be people that you know most people
won't right but some people will go Ah
that's my opportunity then and not that
you know not that it was
not that Trump's set up to be indicted
and arraigned here
um but you know given how everyone is
playing it it may end up being good for
him
no I don't get it
okay the test of the hypothesis that
this was their uh judgment in error that
this was going to be a campaign speech
rather than relevant to something
newsworthy like an arraignment is that
then they would realize upon hearing the
speech oh that was newsworthy one end to
the other we will now broadcast it in
its entirety okay I can't say for sure
that they didn't pick some hour late in
the night and do that but I do not
believe they broadcast that speech in
its entirety which they had an
obligation to do because it was news and
the fact that it contained his defense
and that that defense actually casts uh
a very
serious Paul over the idea that we are
living in a Democratic Republic right we
are now living in a in a a nation
in which a sitting president is his
justice department is having his leading
political opponent
jeopardized with uh
obviously the equivalent of life in
prison and well beyond for a crime that
his opponent did not likely commit but
that he himself did commit now we will
come back to what role Biden actually
plays in this uh later here but my point
is this could not possibly be more
newsworthy and if they thought something
else was going to come out of Trump's
mouth and if they somehow mistakenly
understood their job as to be to decide
what was worth hearing and not hearing
rather than anything Trump says in the
aftermath of being arraigned on federal
criminal charges is worth hearing
doesn't matter how inarticulate or full
of lies it is it's still worth Hearing
in this case but that's not what was
delivered and the fact that I do not
believe that they reversed course and
broadcast the whole thing upon
discovering their errors as it wasn't an
error it was political
and like with so much with MSNBC and CNN
the idea is
the pretense that hey you've turned in
for you know access to the truth and we
know this is Trump so it's not going to
be true it's going to be the inverse of
true and therefore it is Our obligation
to do something else with this time
rather than let you hear what he said
for himself and then he goes on to
deliver his legal defense in public and
people aren't going to hear it they're
going to assume that what he did was Lie
right that is MSNBC
um revealing the game and that is really
the point well so you know one thing
there if if if we had one and only one
you know state-owned media outlet and it
was MSNBC and they said yeah we're not
going to share this live and then and
you don't know I certainly don't know
but and then they did not say that they
did not broadcast it later and there was
no other way for it to get out that
would be a
much different situation I'm I am I'm
not defending them here although I don't
know that I wouldn't if I had more
information but presumably
the speech is broadcast I mean you said
you watched it sorry it's out there
otherwise it's not that MSNBC
um by nannying its viewers is keeping
those viewers from having access to it
but they certainly make it less likely
that most of their viewers will end up
watching it right but I mean look we
live in a democracy or a Democratic
Republic is the proper way to say it and
the idea that you are going to take some
large fraction of the voting audience
and you're going to add obstacles to
their doing this so instead of tuning in
and seeing the news what they're going
to have to do is go find the news for
themselves in some channel that they
don't happen to be watching right that
is this is a kind of election meddling
right that's what this is is pretending
that you've got a narrative of history
and we're not going to let you see any
of the stuff that would discover that
would allow you to discover that it was
untrue and you know I will also point
out
we had a situation
in which
um the cruddy [__] that MSNBC puts
on and CNN puts on was counterbalanced
by the cruddy [__] that fox puts on
and you could by dodging back and forth
between these things makes some sort of
a corrective right but we actually know
what happened here at Fox because
somebody at Fox did put up a Chiron uh
in the aftermath of the Trump
arraignment that's the text that Scrolls
across the bottom of the screen I don't
think the Chiron is the sum total some
of it Scrolls some of it doesn't yeah
show the show this uh screenshot
so somebody want to be dictator speaks
at the White House after having his
political rival arrested now that is
this is this week yeah that is of course
a provocative bit of text and and you
know and the picture they've chosen has
you know has Biden looking
uncharacteristically strong well it is I
believe it must be taken from that uh
speech with the red background doesn't
look like that backdrop but um okay well
in any case look
MSNBC broadcast
[__] Trump is going to lie we know
it because it's what Trump does I mean
it's what Trump is we're not going to
show you lies because we're a news
organization not a lives organization
okay that's [__] okay this was news
Fox came up with some [__] of its
own which is it took a scenario in which
one interpretation is that this is
actually uh you know Banana Republic
stuff unfolding right here in America
and it gave an extreme interpretation
too want to be dictator does Trump want
to be I mean does Biden want to be a
dictator I I doubt he's got it left in
him you know some ice cream I think he
wants some ice cream too so you know do
I agree with you know what fox put on
the screen no but is it worse than what
MSNBC did No in fact you know it at
least raises an interesting question and
what matto did was prevent the raising
of an interesting question is he maybe
just innocent of the crime because he
was president and for whatever reason
the president has absolute authority to
do what he did right
msnbc's audience isn't going to get to
that question yeah I mean I guess
um
one of the things that the last three
plus years now has made abundantly clear
to me
is how rarely when uh Talking Heads of
any sort so-called journalists so-called
heads of public health organizations Etc
make pronouncements are they actually
speaking from knowledge
right did they actually go and look at
the thing and do they know firsthand
that
these are safe and effective
this is almost certain to be a lie and
therefore now you know what matto said
and you know the safe and effective
proclamations about vaccines that
couldn't possibly be known to be safe
and therefore
is the other thing next to it a lie as
well are different sorts of of
I don't want to say they're both lies
are different sorts of rhetoric
but in both cases what what you see if
you if you look behind the curtain uh is
and you know we saw wilinsky
um when she was still the head of the
CDC say or I don't know if she stepped
down yet who knows
um
but saying on camera things like oh gosh
do you remember you know when we saw
this thing on CNN and then I knew that
the numbers were such and such for
Covenant
you're the head of the CDC you're
getting your data from CNN what is going
on here right like that's I
I'm sorry I'm just I'm still so blown
away and I don't have the specifics on
that particular pronouncement from her
but I thought do any of these people
actually know where they speak
and given that they don't seem to is
that maybe actually
intentional and protective because if
they don't know that they're lying then
it's harder to catch them in the lie
because they're just they've just been
handed a slate it's like you know don't
don't go into the footnotes don't read
the primary literature don't talk to the
scientists don't look at you know don't
ask how the you know how the clinical
trial was actually done don't ask any of
those questions just sort of talk at
this like ethereal what's good for
people what do people want to hear let's
let's stick with the pr guys let's stick
with the marketing and so I mean I think
I think
you know I'm not as thrown by this
particular thing from Maddow and MSNBC
as you are but it also just feels like
yep that's rhetoric that's not
journalism just like it's been rhetoric
not Public Health rhetoric not science
all the way down on all of these topics
constantly right but so I don't know
I think what you're saying is you're not
thrown
okay go for it
the only question here is that I don't
think you could come up with something
more newsworthy in the last year it
doesn't matter what matto said it
doesn't matter if Trump lied for an hour
or anything else the fact of a former
president being indicted on felony
charges and speaking about that is the
most newsworthy thing we could disagree
about the time frame but certainly this
week you know there's they broadcast
every night they have
hours of news most of which is not
newsworthy anyway this is the most
newsworthy thing in recent history
I don't think there's a reasonable
argument against that and what's more if
I can complete your argument
this news organization and all of the
others that look like it the New York
Times CNN Washington Post all of them
are sitting in
a location a niche and preventing real
news organizations from emerging so the
idea that you have news organizations
that do not report the news is not just
oh that's a waste it's oh yeah no
there's opportunity costs they're right
they're taking up space and actively
preventing competitors would be
competitors from getting ground well but
actively therefore keeping people from
actually getting informed yes
I would also point out the punch line to
the Fox News version of this where they
came up with a overly simplistic view of
this turn of events is that the person
who is responsible for putting that on
the screen was quickly fired now
and then there's the other punch line
which was
do you know what cannot be allowed to
happen
you can't zero is a special number
zero is a special number
Tucker Carlson on Fox News was an
example of an exception to zero right
this was a person who was delivering uh
wasn't always stuff we agreed with
although I feel weird even having to say
that right the number of people who
tuned into Tucker Carlson's monologues
and found real value in them regular
regularly and people across the
political Spectrum can you like just
take take a moment away for a moment
um
you and I disagree on Plenty of things
imagine if every time I spoke about you
to anyone else I felt the need to say I
don't agree with everything he says yeah
duh even I don't agree with everything I
say like that's that's not helpful here
I don't think but um but seriously like
the people we love most in the world we
you know if you agree with absolutely
everything they say figure out which one
of you figured out all those things and
then the other review like
grow a pair like get a life like figure
out your own brain and figure out what
things are actually different in your
head and from your experience and what
you think you understand to be true from
what the person who you are apparently
receiving all knowledge from is so like
I too feel that pressure of course right
um especially when talking about you
know people on the right oh I have to
say something nice about someone on the
right just to be clear like I don't
agree with everything this is insane oh
like we none of us agree with everything
that anyone else thinks right and you
know I was joking I don't even agree
with everything I say but the fact is
you know
one's perspective does develop unless
you're anything you know if you read
only then maybe it's just not a relevant
Point here no it's relevant across the
board the point is the idea that I don't
agree with everything X person says if
anything goes without saying it ought to
be that right especially if the person
has anything like a complex perspective
on the world so anyway I take it back
you can figure out whether I agree with
everything Carlson says or not but I do
know lots of people who get a tremendous
amount of value about the way he uh
juxtaposes things and he's very gifted
and eloquent
um and the
fact
I really think in at the end of the day
you couldn't very well have the next
election unfold and have Tucker Carlson
sitting on Fox News at the anchor desk
doing what he does because he would keep
pulling back the curtain on the thing
and it's not pulling back the curtain
because it serves the right because
frankly I don't think that's most of
what he's doing I think he is actually a
patriot and that what he does is he
reveals the hypocrisy of the rulers of
the realm day in and day out and the
they decided to they couldn't shut him
up but what they could do is they could
take away the anchor desk and they could
leave him as another disembodied voice
in the man cave or whatever right
um so
here's the point Fox News is being
snapped into line right Tucker Carlson
is gone he was uncontrollable he's now
uh on his own the producer who put that
aggressive counter interpretations the
inverse of what MSNBC did fired so the
point is okay Fox News is no longer
important or interesting in any way
because the one interesting thing it had
is gone so your point is that the
corrections are happening but uh on the
right my point is
yeah one of those I mean
at least one of those Corrections uh is
uh
is is patently bad for our society yes
and I would point out that what Tucker
Carlson did in his most recent monologue
was comment on this very story and what
he did is not um
was not simple
what he did was he outlined all of the
ways that we know that that claim that
Biden is a wannabe dictator are wrong
because he went through a long list of
things that dictators do and described
how Biden wasn't doing any of them but
of course anybody with the slightest
sense of irony would understand that
there were things that the Biden
Administration is doing
could be mapped onto every one of these
things and that that ought to raise
questions why is it that so many things
do look like what happens in a Banana
Republic if we're not living in a Banana
Republic and mind you
I don't think any of this is simple
right this is you know is Biden to want
to be dictator no as you said he doesn't
want to be a dictator he wants ice cream
I think that's where Biden is what we
have is not a dictatorship it's
something like an oligarchy right
behaving in the same way the people in
question are largely behind the scenes
we don't know their names we don't know
what they sound like but
we can infer from the pattern of
behavior and what is tolerated and what
is not
where we are headed and it is very much
like a um
a a new Twist on a very old theme and
that is the illusion of democracy but
the reality is uh controlled by
something unelected which does not take
our interests seriously more than is
absolutely required to keep itself in
power and that's a terrifying thing
right we're talking about the most
powerful Nation on Earth uh ferociously
armed and under the control of who knows
what with a rapidly declining figurehead
whose administration is uh threatening
to jail its primary political opponents
right that is a frightening set of facts
and I haven't exaggerated anything no no
that was a that was a straightforward
list of uh or description of the
situation and uh
yeah that doesn't sound like what I
thought if you had asked me 10 20 30 40
years ago
the US would sound like I would think
that that might be a description of some
Far off place that could really use the
help of a you know amazing Constitution
like ours yeah and it would be
um a terrifying if you could teleport
that description you know
if you and I could alert our high school
selves that we would be sitting here you
know
in our 50s describing the current state
of affairs in the U.S by those terms it
would be a completely jarring Discovery
yeah now it would fail to compute
yeah it would it would fail to compute
and if you did compute you'd know where
you were in history because you'd know
that other societies had failed and when
they did you would know what tragedies
followed and the idea that we are on
such a trajectory uh
would Escape no rational person hearing
that description yeah
all right is it time for carnivorous
plants it's as far as I'm concerned it's
always time for Canaveral so it's not
always easy to find them no not so much
but yeah not not not so much
um
yeah so I came across a new piece of
research this week about carnivorous
plants and it sent me into thinking a
bit about carnivorous plants and that
was fun I I remember when I got to do
that for a living you know think about
fascinating biology that was that was
awesome
so um carnivorian plants
um the analogy I came up with upon
discovering how many times it has
evolved is like the mangrove habit
um mangroves are plants that grow in
salt water and have an ability to get
rid of the excess salt
um but Mangrove isn't a single thing
Mangrove The Habit that we call Mangrove
has evolved many many times similarly
carnivorian plants has evolved many many
many times uh something like at least
nine separate evolutions of Carnival
including multiple evolutions of Pitfall
traps sticky traps and snap traps okay
multiple evolutions of each of those
types of traps and at least nine
different evolutions of carnivalry so
um I have not looked into the history
The evolutionary history of cranberry
and you're going to ask me questions I
can't answer no I'm going to put one
possibility on the table okay I'm gonna
bet
that there are a lot of cryptic
evolutions of carnivorous that we
haven't spotted ways that plants
trick insects into dying in a place
where they can have their nitrogen
absorbed yeah so actually let me the um
there's a good paper given this 2015
that defines what we so and I think what
you just said would would classify you
as a carnivorous plant not use something
but or less I'm carnivorous but yeah I
mean
um to be concerned to be considered
carnivorous giveness rights a plant must
be able to absorb nutrients from dead
bodies adjacent to its surfaces obtain
some advantage in growth reproduction
and have unequivocal adaptations for
active prey attraction capture and
digestion you are going to be very
impressed to discover that the next
sentence out of my mouth was going to be
the way to distinguish this was going to
be some sort of chemical apparatus for
specifically recovering the nitrogen
that was once contained in those insects
that that would be the the diagnostic
yeah yeah so interesting you know this
says unequivocal adaptations for active
prey attraction capture and digestion
and you've skipped the attraction and
capture well you've skipped the
Attraction part so you're saying
basically that sounds more like um no
why can't I think what's a a vulture is
doing uh scavenger yeah so you're
talking to me about like Scavenging
plants carnivorous plants you could have
scavenger but B
um
I'm really just suggesting that the
ability to cryptically attract we an
attractant right if an attractant is
like some uh you know uh sticky sweet
substance on the surface that attracts
uh insects will spot it right if some
pattern on the leaf causes insects to
mistake it for something it may not we
may not know right away that the pattern
is actually an attractant right because
it doesn't it's not a conventional
attraction and then the so so then the
question you know if I don't know this
definition is the one that we really
need to be you know beholden to here but
attraction capture and digestion
digestion obviously like most plants
can't make
hey
out of a dead insect next to them right
hey Flats
can presumably grass can if you're parts
of it yeah um but uh but
uh the the thing that the carnivorous
plants that you're talking about may not
be doing in the same way that we think
of that might be cryptic as attraction
and capture and you know the cat it's
not really capture if like you did
Attract it through some cryptic means
and you do have an ability to digest it
once it's dead
um but some you know you're attracting
some number of organisms and then most
of them just go about their business and
leave again but actually because the
lifespan of these little flies you're
attracting is so short some number of
them simply die in place and then you
haven't actively captured them and so
does that qualify as carnivorous plants
I still think it does it just doesn't
happen to be the criteria of this
particular definition well I like it
they've set a high bar yeah you've got
to do all these things which that's good
that's the direction no and I think I
mean this paper is is um pretty great
new evidence on the origin of
carnivorous plants the short paper
proceedings of the National Academy of
Sciences so it's in you know penis from
four seasons of the National Academy of
Sciences that's always a strange little
acronym to say out loud isn't it yes and
people who publish in lesser journals
suffer from penis envy yes yes yes they
do okay but um that's just sort of a
setup of carnivorous plants carnivory's
evolved lots and lots of times the bar
for whether or not you're considered
carnivorous is high as we've just talked
about
um two stories
um the first of which is what led me
here and then the second of which I've
discovered while I was in the sort of
rabbit hole of plant Carnival that I
think may be actually even cooler
the first one research out I guess it's
actually in in May of this year
facultative Carnival
okay facultative carnivorous uh here we
have a picture and we'll just put this
picture of this pretty pretty little
plant up for just a moment uh and this
is this is a science news piece and it
was about
um about a piece published in a
different Journal which I'll go to in a
moment inducible carnivory okay so I can
read my screen back if you would yet
um
there's only one species of out of all
the hundreds of species of carnivorous
plants known to be facultatively
carnivorous meaning
mostly when you think of like a venus
fly trap or an appenthes or something
it's obligate like you're this is what
you do for a living is you attract
insects and you digest them and that's
how you get your resources but what
about faculty of Carnival where
sometimes it pays to be carnivorous and
sometimes it doesn't
well that's what this one plant is doing
um and so they live in West Africa
they've got this tropical Monsoon
climate shallow acidic highly weathered
soils with low nutrient levels so a lot
like a the wrestling in a landscape
that's hard to pull nutrients from and
the tropical Monsoon climate means that
it's highly variable and somewhat
stochastic throughout the year okay with
regard to what's available to them and
what this research finds is
um
that
when the growth medium is considered
normal like you know basically even
um appropriate I don't remember exactly
what the ratio you got a prediction well
hold on a second if I'm if you said it
okay
um
from the point of view of our listeners
and viewers yeah
these plants are getting nitrogen that
is the limiting thing that they are
getting from their carnivory they're not
getting uh carbon compounds they're not
getting energy these are photosynthetic
plants who are getting nitrogen in no no
um I mean that's precisely This research
was like well what is you know if they
are and if if there's carnivore that is
inducible by environmental circumstances
what is induced in the carnivore what is
it that makes them sometimes carnivorous
and sometimes not and and in this case
it's like three different types of
leaves and one of the leaves is sticky
and and and draws in insects and then
they can digest them so what are the
conditions
you are you are correct that they're not
getting carbon compounds but wait wait
am I incorrect that a venus fly trap or
a nepenthes pitcher plant
um
are getting nitrogen and that this plant
may be doing getting something else or
am I wrong about the entire category of
carnivorous plants I think um
we're wrong only in that um you're it's
it's too simple and like if you think
about gardening if you think about you
know we we don't buy fertilizers but you
know it's it's it's three elements that
tend to be limiting
um uh or that tend to be out of out of
the right ratio it's hydrogen
um phosphorus and potassium okay okay uh
and so what this research does is looks
at those three and says we're gonna
we're gonna provide
um a relative a normal ratio I don't
remember what that is and then we're
going to provide growth medium in which
nitrogen levels are low and one in which
the potassium limits are low deficient
in potassium and one in which phosphate
the phosphorus levels are low and only
when the phosphorus levels were low did
the carnivorous leaves develop so in
this particular case it wasn't the
nitrogen it wasn't the potassium it was
the phosphorus now they're in
particularly
different kinds of soils right these
highly weathered tropical soils uh with
that are you know low nutrients in
general with monsoons coming through
that are presumably helping Leach the
soils further uh so you know I don't I
don't know if more often it's nitrogen
but I wouldn't think that it was
inherently nitrogen even though even any
more than I would think it was
inherently phosphorus or inherently
potassium these are the two these are
two separate questions that may be the
same right there's a question about what
triggers the morphology in which
carnivory happens and so from a
trade-off perspective the interesting
thing here is the reason that we have
carnivorous plants and other plants the
reason that those are in general not
it's not a facultative question is that
a carnivorous plant is not able to
compete with non-crenivorous plants
where non-carnivorous plants have
sufficient nutrients to do their thing
so I suspect you know neither of us are
soil chemists right but I suspect
that you're thinking it's going to be
nitrogen more often than it's phosphorus
or potassium because we know that there
are all of these tricks for nitrogen
fixation in the soil that some plants do
and then others can make use of their
nitrogen and all of this but I don't
know that there aren't comparable tricks
for phosphorus and potassium
deficiencies as well I mean well I'm not
I wasn't actually even going to that
level the question is the fact that you
discover that low phosphorus triggers
the production of carnivorous morphology
doesn't necessarily say that what the
plant needs is phosphorus or that it's
getting phosphorus it just says that
you've got a trigger which could be that
it needs phosphorus and this is a way to
get it from insects or it could be that
that's a good proxy that tells you when
you're in a kind of soil in which
nitrogen will be limiting and it is
picking up nitrogen from the insects but
it's triggered by the low phosphorus
right I could imagine that like for
example but why wouldn't I mean if if
it's a proxy for I need nitrogen why
wouldn't low nitrogen trigger it as well
um it might be for example
that so you're talking about a trigger
which is going to precede the production
of leaves that are capable of remedying
the deficit and so there's a delay there
yep right so it could be that there's
some sort of pattern like if there's a
leaching issue that the soils are going
to be depleted by the high flow through
of water or something like this I agree
with all that but this feels like
epicycles to me why is it so strange
that they might be limited and one of
the things that we know plants in our
agricultural system is limited by it I
won't be surprised by this I won't be
surprised by this at all if so why are
we working so hard to recover the but
maybe it's nitrogen after all
explanation well I'm not trying to
impose that on this plant that I've
never heard of okay okay okay my
question you know if I'm perfectly ready
to accept that I've misunderstood Venus
fly traps on the basis that you know the
textbooks have been wrong and it's not
about nitrogen that could be so your
question is so again at least nine
different evolutions for carnivorian
plan right
um your question is you thought that in
general maybe across all or most of the
evolutions of carnivorian plants it was
driven by a need to pull in nitrogen
from nitrogen nitrogen deficient soils I
don't know I don't I don't know the
answer right and you hinted at the
reason that that would be such a common
motivation for the evolution of this
which is that nitrogen fixation is
actually a tricky business that most
plants can't do right and so there are
various uh you know mutualisms that
bring in nitrogen or you could eat bugs
or you can eat bugs right so the point
is there's lots of ingenious solutions
to this puzzle and the one that is
captivating to us is the consumption of
animals by plants that was fascinating
that plants do that yeah
um but in any case the idea that
nitrogen poor soils happen all the time
for various reasons that lots of plants
can't grow there they are actually
excluded by the lack of nitrogen which
then creates a niche for any plant even
an inferior plant that can figure out
how to beat that limit which is why we
get the evolution of carnivorous plants
but the point is you know if I can grow
there and nobody else can then it you
know the the limit on everybody else's
growth there saves me from all this
competition right but so this is why I
find it analogous to the mangroves right
like lots of evolutions of this habit
that is marginal where you're going to
be at the edge of what most of your kin
and I'm talking about kin broadly like
most plants could possibly tolerate but
poor nitrogen is something that
biologists think about a lot more than
um you know Farmers think about poor you
know poor poor phosphorus and poor
potassium soils as well and you know in
in this particular case it seems to be
about about the phosphorus yep well
again I just I'm not saying it isn't
about the phosphorus I'm just saying
that it to discover that the phosphorus
deficit triggers the evolution of this
morphology doesn't necessarily say that
what the plant is then getting yeah yeah
yeah I don't know about the evolution of
them right triggers the deployment of
this evolved adaptation right it could
still be about nitrogen or not I'm just
agnostic about that until
you know until that that research
um
the other story I ran into about
carnivorous plants though uh some work
published um some number of years ago
2009 I found uh even more Charming
uh even though it involves poop
really yep all right so uh here goes
it's an empathies uh lepentes low EI uh
we said we knew nepenthes in Madagascar
we saw pitcher plants so uh there are a
couple of different Origins as I've
talked about uh evolutions of pitcher
plants but nepenthesis is one of the
giant clouds that's kind of all over the
what is the dangling picture with the
yeah although in some species including
nepenthes loaii they have both a
terrestrial form and an aerial form and
it's different by the age of the plant
so in this Sky nepenthes low EI um they
live in Borneo
against carnivorous pictures at ground
level when the plants are young and just
standard like you know they got these
pictures and I think they you know
closed shut when they've got an insect
in them some of them do I'm not sure
these guys do whatever it doesn't matter
um but once older the pictures change
structure
and um and they never they don't attract
invertebrates at all in fact the
slippery slopes of the terrestrial
pictures that um help
um you know they track the insects and
then once there they can't get they
can't get traction and they slip in and
then they get digested the um these
pictures once the plant gets older and
they're now raised off the ground they
get more robust they change the shape
they're not slippery at all they
actually have like footholds
and
what they have in them
is tree shru poop
and the trees grows
and I've got a picture here
the tree shoes
here you go
um
the tree shoes are being offered some
sweet nothings some sweet stuff by these
nepenthes
and the depanthees the adult nepentheses
that have these aerial pictures
have modified their structure
sufficiently such that when just like
with pollinators right when they're
getting the sweet stuff from the plant
their anuses are positioned just so so
that they poop into the nepenthes and
something over 50 up to a hundred
percent of the nitrogen this time
that these plants have in them is
derived from tree tree what was the
percent over 50 up to 100 that's
incredible isn't that that is incredible
completely incredible let me get the
actual number uh 57 to 100 of the foliar
nitrogen immature and appendix low AI
are from tree shrew
so okay
this this is this is incredible because
in some sense it is
an additional so we have flowers in
which typically a plant effectively
hires an animal to transport pollen over
a distance that the plant can't uh
Traverse right or
another way to think of it is to
radically reduce the amount of pollen
necessary in order to reach a mate
instead of a wind pollinated thing which
fills the air with pollen it's tiny
pollen grains are transported on an
insect or a bird or something like that
so that's one version of plants hiring
animals
we've got forgivory in which plants uh
hire animals in a different way to
transport a seed to transport the seed
into a new habitat or to escape
competition from the parent plant right
these are very classic examples familiar
to everybody but this is really
similar yeah it is it's so similar it's
the hiring of an animal to collect in
this case it's a shrew it's probably
eating the very same insects that the
plant would be collecting but it's
hiring this animal to go out
intelligently find those insects collect
them and then poop in the pitcher and
it's getting its nitrogen that way so
although this is not a it's not a
strategy that has taken over tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of
plants the way fruit and and flowers
have but nonetheless it's you know it's
an equally powerful demonstration of the
idea of plants hiring animals to do
things that you have to be mobile to do
and plants aren't mobile that's right no
it's it's utterly extraordinary so this
work was published in 2009
Clark at all the title is tree shrew
Laboratories a novel nitrogen
sequestration strategy in a tropical
pitcher plant and I'm going to go out on
a limb here yeah
going based on just that one black and
white picture which I've seen for all of
45 seconds here we can put it back up
looks like the reward is being offered
on that cap structure yeah right so
imagine for a second that
again I could be totally wrong about
this but that shrew is probably
uh an insectivore at the dietary level
it's it's in a member of the insectivora
if it's a true shrew right that's a tree
shoes I don't know oh right right yeah
well okay so I don't know if it's an
insectivore but the chances are the way
this evolved if it is an insectivore is
that insects were being
um
attracted to nepenthes because that's
what the Panthers does the true shrew
was using the nepenthes as an attraction
it was parasitizing in the penalties it
was eating insects and the
the uh nepenthes the pitcher plants that
facilitated rather than thwarted this
Behavior came out ahead because some
fraction of the time the tree shrew
would poop in the picture and it would
get nitrogen more than it lost to the
insects that we're taking yeah no I mean
you could I mean we could do a whole
I'm not actually dismissing this at all
but a whole like arm waving story here
where okay it was attracting the insects
and uh the tree shoe was like trying to
grasp but he's slipping because it's
slippery because it needs to be slippery
for the insects to go in and the
nepenthes it gets a little bit stickier
um maybe loses more insects but gets
more tree shoes and the tree shoes start
um to show up for the insects but also
maybe oh there's a little bit of a sweet
reward and so you get a little bit of
positive feedback there and then you get
a modification of the size and shape of
the picture such that when grasping in
exactly this way yeah the tree poops
exactly into the plant and the plant
gets all of that nitrogen yeah I don't
think this is uh you know hand wavy at
all the place it could falter is if the
tree shoe doesn't eat any of the things
that the the panthees attracts yes yes
or attracts in its younger form right
yeah but the idea and you can in your
mind just see it happening right you've
got this picture that is adapted to trap
insects it attracts a parasite the tree
shrew and uh that parasite behaves in a
way that actually causes the pitcher to
recover exactly the reward that it's
built to recover but in a way that is
not anticipated and then its structure
modifies to orient the tree shoes so it
more frequently poops in the picture
yeah and by putting the reward in an
increased level at a place that orients
the Shrew it all works out so basically
it's a it's a gentle slope on the
Adaptive landscape from a modif it's
it's a
it's actually a beautiful demonstration
of why the term exceptation is so
useless good let's do it um so
acceptation is uh I don't know if
Stephen J gold came up with it but he
used to tell this Stephen J Gould uh is
um highly regarded amongst people who
are not evolutionary biologists The
evolutionary biologist by and large hate
him because he uh it was uh
politically motivated to Discount
stories of adaptation
um but anyway the the term is
acceptation acceptation means that uh
instead of something being evolved for
the job it is borrowed for the job and
it was evolved for something else and
the problem it's original it's original
use was it's adaptive use but if the
it's the if the organism is now using
that structure that evolved for
something else for something new that's
not an adaptation it's an expectation
acceptation and the problem with it is
that absolutely every adaptation is
going to be you know many acceptations
because we're all so far from the origin
of whatever we were that everything's
been borrowed multiple times on the
route to getting a little bit it's it's
this like times it's like it's ecology
is mistake in general with Evolution
it's the mistake of like well you know
the first people it's like are you sure
they were the first peoples because I
feel like they were probably people here
before them and uh probably the people
that we're talking about as the first
peoples
um did some stuff to get rid of the
people who came before them and you know
like start counting somewhere and decide
that that's the beginning of history but
but be clear about that's what you're
doing so the same thing same same
problem all adaptations are going to be
acceptations and in this case you can
see it right because you can see the
pitcher plant if the story that we are
intuiting must be uh approximately right
here you've got a picture that is
adapted to collect nitrogen from dead
insects that it tricks into falling into
a trap where they drown
and is being modified to instead of
picking up insects to adjust the
behavior of a would-be parasite who
becomes a collaborator on the basis that
it gets a reward and having collected
insects itself and therefore having
nitrogen that it's not using drops it
into the picture I mean it's even
possible
even possible and again you know maybe
you know I don't know
um but that the tree shoe benefits also
not just from the reward but from having
its poop harvested so that it's not
leaving a chemical trail out in the
forest as to where it's been and where
it might be findable by would-be
Predators yep that's going to be a tough
one but I absolutely agree this is
largely how mammals get hunted is they
leave unavoidable evidence that a
predator with a good sense of smell can
find which explains interesting
behaviors like cats burying their poop
and uh one of the two um sloths in
Central and South America coming down
the tree and actually burying its poop I
think it also accounts for the other one
coming down the tree and pooping but not
burying it right yeah which is which but
yes which actually but um but anyway all
of these things are about disguising
where you are because something if it
figures it out can uh can predate you
well in the case of cats probably it's
more about so your prey don't know
you're there
I don't think so I think it's you know
this is small cats and uh big cats don't
do this
good question I don't know but
um in the small cats I would say uh
hiding from predators is more likely but
it'd be interesting if bit cats do it
then that would suggest that it might
also be be prey Adams yeah
all right that's uh that's carnivorous
plants for you today that's carnivorous
plants versus yes thank you for tuning
in to carnivorous plants today
we will have one and only one more
episode of good neighbor's plants a day
and it will be a long time in the future
right because I'm just I think I think I
now they're amazing like we've we've run
into carnivorous plants in the wild and
they are truly extraordinary you really
can't spend a long time watching them
but we're not going to spend time
watching carnivorous plants while on air
are we no no they're they're they're
some of them are fast for plants but
they're not fast enough that now we want
to become and we do not want Spectators
spectating our spectating of the no it's
terrible being observed while you're
observing yes it's the worst who will
observe maybe not the worst yeah
all right uh I think that brings us to
the end of near the end we're going to
do some uh
some housekeeping at the end here of yet
another episode of
Dark Horse
um you have been hard at work recording
a bunch of guest episodes there was one
that came out this week with Pierre
Corey and they'll be in well we're so we
are going to come to you next Wednesday
so we'll be back uh shortly and then
next Saturday uh there will be another
guest episode and then another one on
that following Wednesday and then we'll
be back the following Saturday and then
we are going to start
um most of live streaming on Wednesdays
starting in July
11 30 a.m Pacific but of course we will
continue to have all of our shows
available in all the normal ways so if
you can't tune in then well but you
could tune in on Saturdays apologies for
that um
some to change it up
and soon we're going to have a website
where all of those schedule changes will
be posted so that will be easier to
track that way
so until
um until we see you next time if you
want to find more of what we're doing I
read it Natural Selections that piece
that we were talking about in the first
part of the couple hours today
um
what is on natural
selections.substack.com this week
Brett's got Twitter subscriptions going
it seems subtle on the Twitter site but
uh it's uh yeah I don't know how subtle
it is because I can't when I look at my
page it doesn't
reveal itself but anyway yes they are
there so uh
consider joining consider consider
signing up um we've got merchandise at
dark store no
darkhorsestore.org great print shop
great couple who make all of our stuff
uh and we're gonna have some new a
little bit of new merchandise soon based
on something you said last week I've got
our amazing artist working on uh working
on art for that
um let's see we've got Hunter gathers
got the 21st century signed copies
available right here in the San Juans at
darvilles which you can d-a-r-b-i-l-s
which you can
order online or of course you can get
the book anywhere and tomorrow on Sunday
July no June something June 18th we have
our private q a at 11 A.M Pacific for
two hours questions have already been
asked but it's it's nice and small and
we do actually watch the chat on that
one and interact with people it's a lot
of fun so if you want to join that um
it's fun nice community of people yeah
yeah it's great um go over to my patreon
and sign up for that Brett's patreon has
a couple of conversations a month as
well and we are going to be moving stuff
over to locals we've got
um people signing up at locals that's
great keep doing that and we will be
sure yep
um and add both of our patreons and
we'll be also with your locals we have
our Discord community
where you can engage in honest
conversations about difficult topics you
enjoy a book club some karaoke virtual
happy hours maybe all at once
absolutely probably not
um but a young or old left or right male
or female is a spot for new around the
Discord campfire
and they also send us a question each
week so we will start the Q a which will
begin in about 15 minutes with a
question from the Discord
and we invite you to check out our
wonderful sponsors for this week once
again that was uncruise Seoul and Seed
all fabulous I didn't say it this time
but we choose our sponsors very very
carefully we don't accept any that
I'll truly vouch for so as always those
three this week are fantastic and we're
supported by you so um share subscribe
like talk about things you're learning
here like
um free Fruit poop with your friends
maybe not over dinner but um you know
anytime else and if your friends can't
handle it they're probably not worthy
friends
or just not biologists maybe yeah
um I don't know I would think I would
think a true friend could handle it even
if it wasn't their uh their cup of tea
even at dinner
uh you might wait till uh you know after
dinner drinks of course yeah yeah I
think that's wise I think that's wise
okay until we see you next time be good
to the ones you love eat good food and
get outside defend the Republic
[Music]
yeah
foreign
[Music]